here we are with permission mr speaker i
would like to make a statement on the
tragic death of sarah everard
and the events of saturday evening i
would like to begin by saying that my
thoughts and prayers with sarah's family
and friends at this unbearable time and
i know that every member of this house
will join me in offering her loved ones
our deepest sympathies while this is a
horrific case
which has rightly prompted debate and
questions around wider issues
we must remember that a young woman has
lost her life
and that her family is grieving mr
speaker let me turn to this weekend's
events
i have already said that some of the
footage circulating
online of clapham common is upsetting
so whilst the police are rightly
operationally independent
i asked the metropolitan police for a
report into what had happened
this government backs our place in
fighting crime and keeping the public
safe
but in the interests of providing
greater assurance
and ensuring public confidence i have
asked her majesty's inspectorate of
constabulary
to conduct a full independent lessons
learned review
the metropolitan police commissioner has
welcomed this and i will await the
report
and of course update the house in due
course
mr speaker i would like to take a moment
to acknowledge why sarah's death has
upset so many
my heartache and that of others can be
summed up
in just five words she was just walking
home
and while the specific circumstances of
sarah's disappearance are thankfully
uncommon
what has happened has reminded women
everywhere
of the steps that we take each day
without a second thought to keep
ourselves safe
it has rightly ignited anger at the
danger posed to women by predatory men
and anger i feel as strongly as anyone
and accounts shared online in the wake
of sarah's disappearance
are so powerful because every single one
of us
can relate to them too many of us have
walked home
from school or work alone only to hear
footsteps uncomfortably close behind us
too many of us have pretended to be on
the phone to a friend
to scare someone off too many of us
have clutched our keys and our fists in
case we need to defend ourselves
and that is not okay women and girls
must feel safe whilst walking our
streets
that is why we have continued to take
action our landmark domestic abuse bill
is on track to receive royal assent by
the end of april
and this will transform our collective
response
to this abort crime this builds on other
measures we have brought forward
including the controlling or coercive
behaviour offense
and the domestic violence disclosure
scheme known as claire's law
which enables individuals to ask the
police whether their partner has a
violent or abusive
past we have also introduced new
preventative tools
and powers to tackle crimes including
stalking
female genital mutilation and so-called
up skirting
but we can never be complacent which is
why throughout the passage of the
domestic abuse bill
we have accepted amendments from
honourable members
from political parties across this house
the bill now includes new offenses of
non-fatal strangulation
outlaws threats to disclose intimate
images
and extends the controlling occur
coercive behavior offence
to cover post-separation abuse
this is in addition to the bill's
existing measures which include a new
statutory definition of domestic abuse
that recognizes the many forms abuse can
take
that psychological physical
emotional economic sexual
and of course the impact of abuse on
children
as well as the new rules to prevent
victims having to go through the pain of
being cross-examined by their abusers
in family and in civil courts
we all know action is needed to improve
the outcomes for rape cases
and we are currently developing robust
actions as part of our end-to-end
review of rape to reverse the decline in
outcomes in recent years
and mr speaker at the end of last year
in december
i launched the first ever public survey
of women and girls
to hear their views on how we can better
tackle these gendered crimes
on friday in the wake of the outpouring
of grief
i reopened that survey i can tell the
house
as of 11am today the home office has
received
78 000 responses since 6 pm
on friday that is completely
unprecedented
and considerably more than the 18 000
responses received over the entire
10-week period
when the survey was previously open
i'm listening to women and girls up and
down the country
and their views will help to shape a new
strategy on tackling violence against
women and girls
which i will bring forward to this house
later this year
the police crime sentencing and courts
bill which we will mr speaker shortly be
debating
will end the halfway release of those
convicted for sexual offences such as
rape
instead under our law vile criminals
responsible for these terrible crimes
will spend at least two-thirds of their
time behind
bars our new law will extend the scope
of the sexual offences act 2003
with regards to the abuse of positions
of trust something which predominantly
affects young girls
and it will introduce kay's law which
will encourage the police to impose
pre-charge bail
with appropriate conditions where
necessary and proportionate to do so
which we hope will will provide
reassurance and additional protection
for alleged victims in high harm cases
like domestic abuse
i know the opposition will today be
voting against these crucial measures
against measures to support victims of
violent crimes including young women and
girls
finally mr speaker the government is
providing an extra 40 million pounds to
help victims during the pandemic and
beyond
and last month we launched a new
government advertising campaign
hashtag it still matters to raise
awareness of sexual violence services
and ensure victims know where to get
help
mr speaker i want to end by saying that
over the past year
during the coronavirus pandemic the
police have been faced with an
an enviable and immediately difficult
task
it is one for most part that they have
approached with skill and
professionalism
helping to enforce regulations as
determined by parliament
with one crucial objective in mind to
save lives
this house approved those changes by 524
votes to 16 on the 6th of january this
year
sadly as of sunday the 14th of march
more than 125
500 lives have been lost to this
horrible virus
it is for that reason that i'm continue
to urge everyone for as long as these
regulations are in place
not to participate in large gatherings
or attend protests
the right to protest is the cornerstone
of our democracy
but the government's duty remains to
prevent more lives being lost during
this pandemic
finally mr speaker there will
undoubtedly be more discussions of these
vitally important issues
in the days and weeks to come but we
cannot forget
i must not forget that a family is
grieving and i know the thoughts and
prayers of this whole house
are with sarah's loved ones at this
truly terrible time